Ukrainian defensive positions west of
the Frontline city of bakmut
Russian infantry are slowly advancing
into Northern and Eastern residential
areas over the hill
the center of town is almost completely
destroyed
streets are virtually deserted the
blasts of exploding artillery and
Rockets is almost constant
a soldier with the Ukrainian Special
Forces leads us to their bunker
warm dark tunnels lined with weapons and
ammunition boxes
drones feed real-time video of Russian
infantry movement only a kilometer and a
half away
they have a lot of Manpower so they sent
every time their troops like a waves so
we cannot stop every time because we
have less guys and unfortunately we also
lost a lot of guys at this moment
men rest before their next mission often
close combat where trenches are only 20
meters apart
commanders insist we hide their
identities and don't film landmarks
nearby that could give their positions
away
they split into small groups in order to
avoid our artillery and they infiltrate
through residential areas and tree lines
but they also suffer huge casualties
Military Intelligence from our Western
Partners is often not distributed to us
quickly enough on the front lines where
we need it to Target command centers
Logistics hubs and weapons depots
the shelling is getting closer
it's been an intensification of shelling
in the last few minutes
the soldiers here are telling us that up
to 600 Russian soldiers are moving into
new positions in the northeast of the
city
we climb the stairs of a destroyed
Residential Building smoke rises from
fresh strikes a few streets away close
to Russian Hill sections of town
what remains of the lives of people who
fled the fighting lies abandoned in a
destroyed home
Russian forces are gradually surrounding
from solidar around 15 kilometers to the
north
to villages in the southeast
strangling what little remains of life
here as the Ukrainian Army prepared new
lines of Defense Charles Strafford Al
Jazeera bachmort